بعد ان جاء وما نتابعه به الان هي هذه
الوثائق ابعاد كثيره
التي تظهر على شاشتنا الان وهو اول ظهور
لرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب بعد
خروجه من المحكمه ومثوله امامها اليوم ها
هو تشامب في جمع من مساعدي وربما انصاره
ايضا
لا يبدو من الصور اين هو
لكن يفترض ان يكون ما زال في فلوريدا لانه
سيتوجه بعد ذلك الى نيوجيرسي حيث سيلقي
كلمه كما اوضحت احمد هزيم لكن هذا اول
ظهور لدونالد ترامب الرئيس الامريكي
السابق والمرشح للرئاسه
لاول صور له بعد بثوله امام المحكمه نشاهد
هذه الصور ونستمع لما يقال فيها
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لننتقد صوره هو بطل حقيقي لا تقاتلوا
عيد ميلاد لدينا حكومه خارج عن السيطره
[تصفيق]
من رحله رائعه
اذا هذه صور تبعناها ونتابعها الان للرئيس
الامريكي دونالد تشامب في ميامي
بفلوريدا بعد ان وصل الى هذا المكان
بعد مثوله امام المحكمه الفدراليه في
ميامي لما يقول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لدينا دوله ليس فيها
حدود ليس فيها سوى مشاكل ويفعلون ما
يفعلونه وترون الشعب ترون اننا نحب الشعب
ترون الحشود لدينا دوله في تقهر كما لم
يسبق ان رايناها من قبل
سوف ادلب خطاب الليله
وامل ان تكونوا حاضرين
انت ايضا يمكنك ان تحضر اذا اردت شكرا
جميعا
بارك الله شكرا
[موسيقى]